this is absolutely fascinating um the
amount of uh potential criminality that
radical repugnant republican congressman
madison cawthorne has been engaged in is
very high we talked yesterday about him
bringing a knife to a school board
meeting and now being caught with guns
twice at airports the latest is that
madison cothorn appears to be implicated
in an insider trading scheme
and also may have violated the stock act
by failing to disclose a let's go
brandon cryptocurrency purchase now
we're going to go through the details of
the two stories in a moment
but it can't be ignored
that there very clearly seems to be a
concerted effort from the right to
damage madison cawthorne cawthorne a few
weeks ago made headlines by saying he'd
been invited to cocaine-fueled orgies by
fellow members of congress the
republican party didn't like that it
potentially is true either way it
doesn't matter
they seem to now be
uh targeting madison cawthorne and the
uh the the targeting is being done by
republicans so let's start first with an
article in the washington examiner this
is a right-wing publication
madison cauthor implicated in potential
insider trading scheme experts say
madison catherine may have violated
federal insider trading laws as he hyped
up an alleged pump and dump
cryptocurrency scheme multiple watchdog
groups told the washington examiner
on december 29th the beleaguered north
carolina congressman posed at a party
with james katulis a hedge fund manager
and the ringleader of the let's go
brandon cryptocurrency
a meme coin set up in the wake of the
chant mocking joe biden
um kawthorne posted on instagram
let's go brandon legends tomorrow we go
to the moon
the next day lgb coin went bonkers
and the value spiked by 75 percent
multiple watchdog groups told the
washington examiner that the post
suggests he may have had advanced
non-public knowledge of lgbcoin's deal
the watchdog said the post combined with
a statement that he owns the coin
warrant and investigation this looks
really really bad said the government
affairs manager for project on
government oversight similarly
um
he may have violated what's called the
stock act remember insider training
trading and the stock act are two
different things they are related often
when it comes to members of congress the
stock act applies specifically to
members of congress insider trading laws
apply
more generally to everybody but as a
member of congress he may have access to
particular information so there are two
stories here there's the story itself
about madison cawthorne insider trading
violating the stock act bringing guns to
airports all of these
legal issues and the general question as
to whether he's going to be held
accountable for any of it now of course
everybody's innocent until proven guilty
my position unlike the people who go
lock her up lock up hillary wait a
second hillary hasn't been charged and
she hasn't been found guilty you can't
lock her up so i don't say lock up
madison cawthorne i say
there certainly is smoke here so there
should be an investigation and the
investigation should take us where it
will and on that basis if he committed
crimes he should be charged he shouldn't
be exempt from being charged because
he's a member of congress the political
story that is very interesting
is the obviously
concerted effort by the republican party
to oust madison cothorn when the
washington examiner is publishing dirt
on a conservative on a republican i
shouldn't call him a conservative on a
neo-reactionary republican
it may be a signal that the
establishment republican party is done
with him and every indication is that
the cocaine field orgy story is what
sort of put this over the edge and we'll
see what madison cawthorne's future
holds i don't know the answer but at
minimum right now there is plenty of
smoke telling us there should be
numerous criminal investigations going
on we'll follow it we'll see where it
goes
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts my subscription to
aura gives me peace of mind protects my
devices it protects all of my different
accounts and i can monitor everything in
one place on the app if i get attacked
aura actually takes action to prevent
and resolve the issues in real time and
aura is letting my audience try it
completely free for 14 days go to
aura.com
pacman the link is down below